hey everyone this video will be a little
different editor stan my editor for the
last few years is in the process of
moving home and thus could not edit this
video he will be back next week to
finish off the naruto series but right
now my good friend tom will be covering
forums say hi tom come on man i said i'd
edit your damn weeb video just don't
hurt me good to have you on board there
buddy lovely guy that time but he knows
nothing about anime so this will be
funny if nothing else now back to
business over the last couple of weeks
i've covered and reviewed the fourth
shinobi war arc allowing myself to
experience some genuinely great moments
that i think could stand alongside some
of the best moments in the series all
the while brute forcing my way through
some of the absolute worst i've seen in
the story too few things in storytelling
are more offensive to me than boring
exchanges and unfortunately a large part
of this arc's middle section contended
with that very issue i found however
last week's video also ended on a high
note as naruto realized a form
emblematic of his self-acceptance and
unity with his inner demons in other
words naruto has managed to harness the
power of dragon ball super saiyan with
the appeal and all the visual flair of a
digimon fight it sounds silly but it
actually kind of works trust me how will
this conclude i have no damn idea but
we're gonna find out today i'm toying up
mark and this is my final review of the
fourth shinobi war arc its climax and
the penultimate review of the entire
naruto series
[Music]
as i mentioned when we last left off
naruto had effectively achieved super
saiyan became the avatar and formed the
perfect bond with his digimon right in
the nick of time the visuals in the
manga looked stunning and we finally
scratched and clawed ourselves out of
that rut i agonized my way through in
the last video and i'm happy to report
that i enjoy this portion of the ark so
so much more than its middle in my last
video i had a growing issue with the
sheer volume of scenes and how
uninterested i was in them however with
this climax sasuke re-enters the fray
all the while we focus on three specific
conflicts all with three different
flavors thankfully conflict number one
naruto vs toby this was the battle that
made this arc a joy to read once again
for me last week there's such a strong
sense of stakes culmination and profound
occasion within this battle alone that
i'd honestly be happy if this was all we
got as many of you know i'm always a big
fan of techniques that impose their own
unique tensions in a fight and this is
no different when it's announced that
naruto only has five minutes with the
newly acquired fox form i could feel my
attention focus in on the battle even
more and this is great because in the
early stages of this fight kishimoto
ensures that naruto's character remains
consistent by having him not give up on
or take out the remaining bee juice
thanks to his interaction with sun i
can't believe that's his name goku he
knows that he can save all of these
entities he wants to free them naruto
will not compromise on his ethics or
morals and his decisions like this
narratively that make for much more
dramatic circumstances it feels true to
the characters and so as a result it
feels less like an author dragging his
fictional puppets around an artificial
stage and more so a believable decision
that aligns with a specific character's
mindset and philosophy which makes
things all the more exciting and real
capping all of that off with some
outrageously brilliant manga
illustration and paneling to depict the
biju bomb from naruto it feels fittingly
huge and i'll admit i was just sort of
sitting there admiring them for a few
minutes too this is all to say that the
beginning of this fight i loved there's
a tremendous sense of unity and fate
associated with the particular flashback
to the b jews when they were young and
naruto seems to be that connective
tissue and while all of this was great
it's made all the better thanks to the
inclusion of other characters and their
respective conflicts
conflict number two the five kage versus
the reincarnated uchiya madara i think
much of what i like about this fight
comes by way of lady tsunade's
contribution particularly when the first
hokage's image hashirama is used for
intimidation purposes by moderate
pitting the image of her grandfather
against her perceived own lack of
accomplishments he belittles tsunade's
abilities and efforts and sites that
there was only ever one who was worthy
of fighting him the first hokage her
grandfather it's a tried and true cliche
in shonen and storytelling in general
but effective nevertheless when the
target of this ridicule rises to the
occasion proving that the words lobbied
against her were wrong there's some
really nice tsunamis shine here too with
the focus remaining on teamwork above
all else and finally conflict number
three sasuke and hitachi vs kabuto it's
difficult to assert which of these three
fights is my favorite as it constantly
changed from moment to moment each one
offering more narrative goodness to
digest in the last but one i found
myself much more invested in that i was
otherwise anticipating was kabuto's
altercation with hitachi and sasuke
kabuto sort of just been there from the
beginning he's always been a means to an
end for the main bad guy orochimaru i
found him interesting from a utilitarian
standpoint but when it came to him
specifically i never found myself asking
the question who he was or where did he
come from and i think that's part of
what makes kabuto's progression to this
point so appealing and interesting to me
watching him slowly develop more and
more nefarious tendencies more power and
more influence as the story trudged on
forward was enriching and it all came to
a head in this section through an
illuminating flashback that helps to put
us as an audience into the rightful mind
to view him finally and that's not even
to make mention of this
[Applause]
this was a really cool idea to play
around with on behalf of kishimoto
resurrection when it was initially
brought up was something i genuinely
thought was interesting it was a chance
to explore a lot of what-if scenarios
that we otherwise wouldn't get to
explore i did get a little bogged down
last week when the story focused harshly
on one aspect of the resurrection angle
which got very very old quickly
thankfully however this is something
entirely new and it involved another one
of the main characters instead of seeing
two people duke it out we now have
sasuke having been granted the chance to
actually talk to his brother again to
potentially alleviate some of the
emotional baggage he's carrying i mean
like him or hate him sasuke's still just
a kid that's been through hell and back
i'm surprised he even knows which way is
up the moment in time that sasuke's eyes
meet the movement of atachi zooming
through the forest on his way to kabuto
facilitated some of my favorite
illustrative and paneling work from
kishimoto there's a tremendous
commitment to allow this moment and
indeed us as an audience the space and
time necessary to soak this snapshot in
time in there's also no explosions or
anything dangerous it's simply a younger
brother thinking he's seeing a ghost
when his older brother zooms on by with
kishimoto switching from current time to
flashback panels back to present day it
helps to perfectly capture exactly what
sasuke is thinking as he begins to give
chase it's brilliant and brings to light
the potential regret confusion and
amazement sasuke has for how things are
left between them this is a really
intense scene both from a dialogue and
action perspective as i wasn't entirely
convinced i knew where sasuke would land
in terms of aligning himself and while
that made for some intense moments it
also helped me relax and enjoy the
wholesome tag team these two brothers
eventually became and in terms of
callbacks kabuto can now tap into snake
dragon sage mode i'm really glad that
naruto and jiraya weren't the only ones
to tap into this reservoir power and now
that we know how this technique or form
works kishimoto can focus on the
choreography and drama of the situation
it doesn't need to be explained to us
and it's really refreshing to watch
someone else utilize this technique
after so long with a different spirit it
goes a long way in helping this world
feel all the more believable it's great
world building
this video is sponsored by raycon if
you're in the market for new wireless
earbuds that offer the same sound
quality as premium brands at half the
price then raycon's everyday earbuds are
exactly what you need they look sound
and most importantly feel better than
ever each pair comes with their
fantastic optimized gel tips that give
you the perfect in-ear fit i use these
while i exercise all the time so trust
me when i say not only are they super
comfortable but they will not come out
of your ears even during the most
intense sessions i've spoken in the past
about how rarely i need to charge them
but it cannot be overstated with 8 hours
of constant play time and a total of 32
hours of battery life they're always
ready to go when you need them and it's
no wonder they've become so popular
these earbuds have over 48 000 five-star
reviews and it's easy to see why with a
30-day happiness guarantee you can try
them totally risk-free but honestly you
won't need it they're great so if you're
interested in hearing for yourself click
the link in the description box or go to
buy recon dot com forward slash not mark
to get 15 off your recon order
so okay enough being around the bush
let's talk about kabuto's flashback he
was a kid that started from quite
literally nothing he had no memories or
anything and is now one of the most
dangerous people in the known world he
was saved from the ruins of battle and
loved immediately danzo and orochimaru
manipulated the situation taking his
mother away on a mission for the
foundation and kabuto into shinobi
training five years in he kills his
adopted mother inadvertently and she
didn't even recognize him due to the
really screwed up brainwashing practices
that honestly make way more sense that
i'm comfortable with admitting last week
i know i was the there is way too many
flashbacks guy but i sincerely thought
that this flashback in and of itself was
very effective and made me care a lot
more about kabuto as a character he's
been a recurring one for quite some time
now and finally having context for his
actions and the philosophy behind his
connection to hirochimara was refreshing
the flashback itself is quite long with
a fully fleshed out beginning middle and
end it's very much its own
self-contained short story in fact and
by virtue of all of that set itself
apart in my eyes from almost all of the
other short and away flashbacks in the
prior preliminary matchups during my
last video kabuto wants to fill the void
in his life that he's felt since
childhood he wants to be someone and
through that he's found a profound
jealousy with those that can identify as
uchiha someone that can possess a
moniker with which they can identify
themselves as someone rather than what
he believes he might be no one it's
creepy and also very sad it's really
interesting and then we get to the
izanami technique
[Music]
i'm coming to bargains and okay okay
okay before anyone types it i know
kishimoto did this first but i couldn't
help but laugh when i saw that scene the
similarities were too similar that said
i wasn't laughing in a mocking way but
justin that i was having fun with the
moment it's a really cool idea the
technique itself offering up a sacrifice
and specifically praying upon the very
aspect of kabuto's personality that has
caused him to be so dangerous it's a
really cool visual of one that screwed
my head up on first reading but volume
62 hits like a train it wraps up the
conclusion to itachi and sasuke's story
quite beautifully while also providing a
justification for hitachi's horrible
actions that ultimately became the
motivating factors behind sasuke's
entire journey this is a world altering
moment in his young life and the way
it's presented in the manga is stunning
to see unfold there are a lot of really
quiet moments in this volume following
the collapse of kabuto's edo tensei one
that especially caught me off guard was
dan's impromptu reuniting with tsunade
in the middle of battle to protect her
in these situations i've found that less
is more you can present the most
climactic battles i've ever seen and
demonstrate characters performing
death-defying feats of unimaginable
skill and finesse but all of that will
never match the feeling of a single page
spread
of a brother reaffirming his love and
pride in his younger sibling or the
haunting white background when two lost
souls finally find each other once again
and okay
i need to take a few minutes and talk
about what happens from chapter 595
onwards concerning the battle between
the union of kakashi gaia naruto vs toby
it is
amazing and i try not to use that word
lightly but it was a moment that had a
clear and well orchestrated build up
which was delivered in a phenomenally
engaging exciting and mysterious fashion
okay so this might seem like it's coming
from left field a bit but this reveal
reminds me of all the reasons why i
loved early sherlock on the bbc and why
i really grew disinterested in it with
the later seasons when you're writing a
mystery story above all else the most
important component to its narrative
creation is providing the reader or
viewers the chance to successfully piece
the story together for themselves
without a reveal latter seasons of
sherlock seem to focus less on the
mystery and more so on the individual
characters opting for a story driven
specifically by drama and less so about
the mystery itself which i mean is fine
if you like that sort of thing i didn't
but that's just my taste the reason why
the first episode of sherlock this study
in pink worked so well for me was due to
the specific narrative decision made to
anchor it around the answer to a given
mystery during the 90 minute run time of
that very episode we as viewers are
presented a series of murders with the
circumstances they all took place within
furthermore sherlock at one point even
asks himself some pointed questions
quote who do we trust even though we
don't know them who passes unnoticed
wherever they go who hunts in the middle
of a crowd the questions are said aloud
to us to hear intentionally and they beg
us to try and solve it for ourselves and
so the point of all of these inclusions
is the places in the mind of the
individual who's solving the mystery and
when it's eventually revealed or the
person us who pieces it together
eventually does so there's a tremendous
feeling of catharsis as a result both
for the character and indeed us reading
or watching we feel this way we feel the
aha moment if you will because we have
ourselves to blame for solving this
mystery it's an achievement this
naturally builds investment into the
story you're interacting with and
furthermore builds respect between you
and the character who uncovered the
truth and this is exactly what happened
here with kakashi and obito uchia
kakashi throughout this series has been
one of the most observant and patient
shinobi we've come across despite
naruto's massive surge of power in
recent times kakashi still manages to
believably provide utility to the
emerging conflicts in ways only he can
particularly in this instance as the
team tried to scratch toby even once in
an effort to figure out who he really is
and ultimately to formulate a plan of
effective attack in doing so kakashi's
blade scratches the mask of toby and in
that instance the ball drops and kakashi
understands everything about how toby's
jutsu works and moreover who this
individual actually is and the mechanism
with which this story unveils that is
utterly masterful to say the least and
might i say extremely elegant and simple
kakashi was the only one who could have
made this connection successfully
because he's the only other person who
has that same ocular power what a reveal
and as he rationalizes this theory
landing successful attacks my jew
kishimoto himself panels the eyes of
kakashi and toby side by side visually
communicating exactly who this person
actually is before it's revealed giving
us the chance to figure it out for
ourselves and there's tons of stuff that
happened earlier in the story to allude
to this very conclusion too and then we
get the flashback geez okay for a story
that leans far too heavily in flashbacks
this still hit like a train which speaks
to the level of execution this reveal is
operating with we've already seen how
kokashi received his eyes and so this
flashback instead focuses on conveying
to us the humanity the childishness the
hopes the dreams the insecurities and
the early life of obito himself drawing
specific similarities to naruto 2 and
kishimoto does this entirely without any
dialogue it's beautifully handled with
the reveal of who is indeed beneath the
mask cut into the core of kakashi as
seen in his expression despite this
being spoiled for me the magnitude of my
enjoyment horror and excitement i had
while reading this was remarkably high
and remember when i said that volume 62
was really good well volume 63 is even
better and might even be the best in the
series to say i flew through this volume
is an understatement of the century the
volume is filled with either massive
reveals or extended and viciously
interesting flashbacks the likes of
which determine the course of action of
the remainder of the story it's
extremely pivotal and by the way when i
saw uchiyamara as some old guy in the
origin of abita's story i was like wait
what so i guess not all the surprises of
this section were lost on me after all i
think more than anything else what this
volume managed to convey to me is just
how much work kishimoto has put into the
narrative of this story for this
conclusion to involve so many different
characters from so many different
backgrounds and generations each with
their own rich histories philosophies
and motivations all thoroughly fleshed
out by the way for all of that to come
together and then make sense is one of
the most difficult and cathartic magic
tricks a writer can pull off and for me
someone who was spoiled on one of the
foundational reveals contained within
this section to actually enjoy this
immensely should stand as a testament to
the writing acumen of masashi kishimoto
in this instance it's totally incredible
the way everything ties back together in
this scene is a feast for the eyes and
mind watching as kakashi's hero turns
out to be the villain of the century and
then naruto throws his words back at
kakashi only to regain his resolve it
makes me remember that there are three
generations in this fight four if you
count the kage and oh jeez okay i didn't
even mention the entrance mata made
despite the resurrection jitsu being
released he managed to remain and not
just that in the middle of this scene
between naruto and obito
he shows up before the scene switches to
the bloodied heap he left to fight kage
in there's been so much time dedicated
to these villains that i honestly am
just so damn excited to see how this
thing progresses i'm all in though
totally invested these are the best
collection of chapters in the entire
series easily you might have to wade
through a lot of mid shonen in the
second act of this story but holy [ __ ]
is it worth it the battle that rages on
between these two parties is utterly
nuts to the nth degree far beyond
anything i've seen in this series
visually incredible and narratively
captivating watching naruto kurama and
kakashi manage to find a way to survive
amidst all of this chaos is crazy to see
unfold and then kurama runs out of juice
he needs time to regain his chakra and
what's more is the situation worsens the
ten-tailed biju is released and is
ludicrously powerful it's now starting
to look like naruto and everyone is done
for when
[Applause]
it had been so long since we touched
base with these guys i honestly totally
forgot about them again brilliant pacing
by kishimoto here and what's more is
their presence here works double duty
with them not only serving a utility and
by naruto more time to charge but to
also signify the world that naruto and
indeed all of them are fighting for
thematically one of unity and peace they
are as their name suggests allied forces
flying in the face of obito and indeed
madhura it's honestly difficult for me
to articulate and to even accurately
capture the excitement i had while
reading this week to help put it into
perspective normally i read some here
and there as i go about my week while
writing as i go this with this one this
week i read through six volumes in a
single day and i also wrote a lot of
this and it felt like nothing there's
just so many interesting and fun
dynamics at play and they all center
around one ongoing force of evil
moderate and obito's mission to
brainwash and enslave the world and
there are sacrifices too in this that
brought a tear to my eye nedji wasn't a
character i shared a lot of time with in
the story unfortunately but his
sacrifice stood in line with his one
shining moment in the series i did enjoy
throwing a quote back to naruto that he
really needed to hear from a time which
made me realize just how far this
journey has taken me and then we came to
shikaku he has been a character that's
contributed one of the most emotional
sequences in the story and
one that was helped immeasurably by the
anime way back when he's never been in
the spotlight for long and he's almost
always been a supporting character and i
think it's for that very reason that
this particular moment here his
sacrifice hit me so powerfully he's a
terrifically written father type
character unafraid to do what he needs
to in order to give his son his family
and the next generation a future he
believes in this really got me and in
triumphant fashion it's this final
partying gambit that leads to one of the
most incredible unifications of power
facilitated by some of the most unlikely
of sources that gives them this chance
it's it's stunning
kept you waiting huh
i just realized something uh i totally
forgot to mention something super
important so remember kabuto right well
through him sasuke brought urochumaru
back but why to what end you might be
asking well sasuke wants to know the
truth and has some questions for
orochimaru specifically and so long
story short orochimaru might not have
the answers but he has taken sasuke to
kanoa in the middle of a war to help him
answer some of these questions these
questions being what is a village and
what are shinobi and when i saw what
orochimaru did to answer these questions
i was super excited the dude resurrects
all four fallen hokage of the past
everyone from minato all the way to the
very first hokage hashirama and getting
to see all of these characters interact
with each other for the very first time
was hilarious exciting and super
interesting i felt myself hanging on
each and every word exchanged however
after a while the fun and games needed
to come to a close and a much more
serious story and response from
hashirama followed the ignition for this
conversation to actually take place
wasn't necessarily sasuke's request as
pointed out in the story by orochimaru
himself despite the second lord being
the creator of the edu tensei technique
hashirama is the only one capable of
terminating it and thus the decision was
his to make this is the very first time
we've gotten to actually see how
characters interact with hashirama
specifically we've heard grade 10 of his
strength and presence through his former
adversaries but never strayed from the
horse's mouth and i love how candid and
approachable this person is again his
temperament strikes me oddly similar to
that of even naruto and fittingly the
very reason he's chosen to have this
conversation over helping his community
and the world is due to one observation
he's made if he leaves he believes
sasuke will become the next moderate
which makes the introduction of this
flashback all the more epic not for its
action but because this could be a
prelude to the conflict that rests on
the horizon between naruto standing in
for hashirama and sasuke standing in for
madhura as hashirama remarks to himself
the numerous times in this volume always
conflict no matter what the era the
flashback in question that takes place
is by far the most detailed and longest
in the series taking up more than 60
percent of volume 65 it is a fascinating
read comprehensively telling the story
of both matara and hashirama's origins
where their respective points of view
stem from and what led them to defect
from one another and it's that slow
progression to embracing the darkness
that this story does a phenomenal job of
conveying and making sense of beginning
as naive and optimistic children with
plans for a peaceful future eventually
becomes a war of ideology a war where a
vision of a pessimistic reality stands
in opposition to honest optimism for the
future one where the teachings and
ultimately the hatred from both sides
pass on down the poison that ultimately
leads to the downfall of madra and on a
long enough timeline kanoa and the rest
of the world it's such a compelling
story where two children turned brothers
turned sworn enemies have to contend
with the reality that they are faced
with that in life there are no clear-cut
solutions no matter how honest or
well-intentioned you might think you're
being i think alongside the flashback
with obito and madara this flashback is
the best the series has demonstrated and
within which i found myself oddly
attached to the character of hashirama
and even very sympathetic towards
moderate someone i never thought i would
feel any sympathy for but in the end
that's exactly what the story has made
me feel that fighting for a world where
children no longer have to deal with the
looming nightmare of war is worth
fighting for it strips them of their
lives their innocence and in matara's
case their light leaving only darkness
behind time and again with each
subsequent hokage signaling their own
unique shortcomings to one another one
inalienable thought comes to the mind of
hashirama yet again and at the same time
sasuke is left to decide the fate of his
group and indeed his village ultimately
he decides to head towards the
battlefield for alongside each and every
one of these famed shinobi of the past
each flawed on their own rights
hashirama once again reaffirms something
in his mind that there may always be
conflict no matter the era but this time
it will be the end of wars
kakashi is just [ __ ] cool okay there
i said it he's also got the best design
i just love seeing how kishimoto draws
the dude but anyways kakashi and obito
end up fighting and arguing ironically
in a different reality they say that
most great drama comes from people
speaking in rooms without story these
scenarios have no meaning and therefore
lack the qualities that compel people to
listen stripped of all the bells and
whistles but when you can put two
well-established characters in a room
together with conflicting ideologies
then there are few things more
compelling than that the conversation
between kakashi and obito is just that a
compelling conflict of ideology and it
makes me feel all the more sympathetic
for the lost libido and so much more
supportive of the resolute kakashi
there's a portion of this conversation
that succinctly breaks down the exact
argument here for kakashi he says and i
quote the hole in one's heart gets
filled by others around you but people
won't flock to someone who abandons the
memory of his friends and gives up on
the world that won't help fill the hole
in your heart and people don't help
those who run and do nothing so long as
you don't give up there will be
salvation
this is a superbly worded quote that
strikes at the heart of this
conversation the main character of
naruto himself and indeed most of the
major conflicts throughout this entire
series and fittingly as if symbolic of
this result fukashi is vouching for
naruto's and the rest of the shinobi
allied forces resolve is finally
rewarded
this is the part of the video where i
devolve into making nothing but childish
sounds because all of this is just so
damn cool like just when you think
things couldn't get even more awesome
they do within seconds of each other
mind you
[ __ ]
i swear when sasuke showed up and the
first thing he said was that he was
going to become hokage right next to
naruto maybe because of the build up or
the tension i was feeling at the time
but i just burst out laughing i was so
excited to see cell 7 reunited for the
very first time in what feels like
hundreds of chapters fighting alongside
each other for their village's
well-being so much of what transpires
from this point on is wall-to-wall or
should i say page to page action it's a
feast for the eyes and even made me
someone that's only recently picked up
naruto feel an incredible amount of
nostalgia and everything just comes
together in the best of ways during this
section shikamaru takes over from his
dad in formulating a strategy heck
sakura makes it known that she knows how
to fight using the diamond on her
forehead like tsunade which i wasn't
expecting but again totally loved there
are so many interesting little dynamics
at play exploding around the environment
it's here that naruto as a story truly
basks in the time it's taken throughout
the series in building up its characters
everything from something innocuous like
kiva looking for attention in becoming
hokage to something dastardly like
madara's shifting demeanor when
kashirama shows up this is the result
and man is it spectacular we even get a
recreation of one of the early
illustrations by kishimoto with cell 7
standing front and center showing the
full scope of how far everyone has come
in such a long time span i just know
there's going to be so much more
conflict between these three
particularly naruto and sasuke so much
so that i'm just going to enjoy this
brief interlude in the violence and
fighting because things are about to get
really
really bad for everyone
[Music]
guys this is where i'm gonna have to
leave off this week next week will be my
final naruto video covering this series
i can't believe i'm saying that it's
been so long make sure to like and
subscribe for more long running series
like this but until then i've been toy
nutmark and thank you all so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]